I wish you were here with me are you  okay I'm hearing lots of things about a  ship breaking up the captain's gone sir  we got maybe two three hours and then we  sink what's this on the radio  he's a tanker split right in half chief  get yourself a crew you assist that ship  it's gonna be hard to eat strength in an  hour  the Coast Guard they say you gotta go  out don't say you gotta come back in  who's coming with me  here we go no one's getting out of there  in this weather it's your job to go out  right I promise you I'll come back  every fella here wants to live the only  way that happens is if we work together  to suicide mission the compass is gone  it was better gonna die unless we can  reach them in time we got no idea where  they are  we lost the pugs  the finest hours rated pg-13 in theaters  January 29th tickets on sale now